From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. So, Nancy Updike has been a producer making stories here at This American Life, starting with our very first episode back in the 1990s.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台的《美国生活》节目。我是艾拉·格拉斯。南希·厄普代克从20世纪90年代我们制作第一期节目开始，就一直担任《美国生活》的制作人。
And when Nancy takes on a big story, it is very exciting for me and the other producers here because nobody writes or reports a story the way that Nancy does. She just throws you in there with the people that she's writing about, and you're in so deep so quickly. And there's this just intimacy to it. It's got such a feeling to it.
当南希负责一个大型选题时，我和其他制作人都感到非常兴奋，因为没人能像她那样写作或报道故事。她会让你迅速沉浸在她所描述的人物中，让你很快就深陷其中。这种故事有着一种独特的亲密感，非常有感染力。
And she has a new podcast. It is called We Were Three. She made it with her coworkers who make Serial. And today, on the show, I'm going to play you the first episode of her podcast, and you'll hear what I'm talking about for yourself. That's going to be the first big chunk of today's show.
她有一档新的播客，叫《我们是三人组》(We Were Three)。这是她与《Serial》节目的同事们共同制作的。今天，我将在节目中播放她播客的第一集，你亲耳听过就明白我所说的了。这将是今天节目开头的大部分内容。
And then after that, we have another story for you of somebody who is digging around in their family's past, like the woman who's at the center of Nancy's story. And just, let's just get to it. I think actually saying more about Nancy's story will not add to the listening experience of it. So here's Nancy Updike.
在那之后，我们还有另一个故事，讲述的是像南希故事中那位主角一样，深入挖掘家族过往的人。我们直接进入主题吧。我觉得关于南希的故事，多说无益，反而会影响听感。所以，有请南希·厄普代克。
Rachel McKibbens and her dad, Pete Camacho, stopped talking and resumed talking many times over the course of her life. He could be generous. He could be mean and drunk. She learned how to be mean.
瑞秋·麦基本斯和她的父亲皮特·卡马乔在她的一生中，多次经历过停止交流又恢复联系的过程。他既能慷慨大方，也可能刻薄且酗酒。她学会了如何变得尖刻。
She left California, moved across the country. She loved him when she could, and she never wrote him off. She made sure her kids knew the good version of him. When COVID started, Rachel and her father were in a barely talking phase. But a few months in, he emailed her.
她离开了加州，搬到了全国的另一端。她在力所能及的时候爱着他，从未彻底放弃他。她确保自己的孩子们了解他好的一面。新冠疫情刚开始时，瑞秋和她父亲处于几乎不说话的阶段。但过了几个月，他给她发了封邮件。
Trying to find the email where he reached out. So I think the word was "infusion."
我在找他联系她的那封邮件。我想那个词是“注资”。
Infusion meant he was sending money.
“注资”意味着他要寄钱。
Yep, here we go-- "infusion." I was right.
是的，找到了——“注资”。我猜对了。
She opened the email.
她打开了那封邮件。
And it said, "Just want to be sure that my New York family is safe in all of this. Please, if there's anything you need, let me know. We're family after all." And I was like, OK, here's an olive branch.
上面写着：“我只是想确认我在纽约的家人在这一切中是安全的。如果有任何需要，请随时告诉我。毕竟我们是一家人。”我就想，好吧，这是橄榄枝。
He sent $1,000 to her bank account-- an infusion. It saved the day. Rachel and her partner at the time, Jacob, ran a bar and restaurant in Rochester, New York. It was closed-- COVID. They were strapped. They had three kids at home, out of five. A year or so later, conversations with her father were very different. Her father was insisting that Rachel not vaccinate his grandkids, her children. He called it murder. When she pushed back, he'd ridicule her.
他往她的银行账户里汇了1000美元——一笔“注资”。这真是救了急。当时，瑞秋和她的伴侣雅各布在纽约罗切斯特经营一家酒吧和餐厅。因为疫情，店关了。他们手头很紧。家里有五个孩子中的三个。一年左右后，她与父亲的谈话大不相同。她父亲坚持要求瑞秋不要让外孙们接种疫苗。他称之为谋杀。当她反驳时，他就会嘲笑她。
Rachel stopped talking to him. She didn't bother telling her father when she, her two youngest kids, and Jacob all got COVID in the fall of 2021. Even when Jacob went into the ICU for five days and the doctors told her to pray, she still didn't reach out to her dad for support. Four days after Jacob was finally released from the hospital and back home with Rachel and the family recovering--
瑞秋停止了与他的交流。2021年秋天，当她、她两个最小的孩子和雅各布都感染了新冠时，她甚至没去告诉父亲。即使雅各布在重症监护室待了五天，医生让她祈祷时，她依然没有向父亲寻求支持。在雅各布终于出院、回到家中与瑞秋一家团聚康复的四天后——
At about midnight, my brother sent me a text that said, I've been too distraught to tell you, but Dad passed away today at 2:42 PM because of--
午夜左右，我哥哥发短信跟我说，我太心烦意乱以至于没法告诉你，但爸爸今天下午2:42去世了，因为……
This was a text?
这是短信告诉你的？
Yeah.
是的。
A text telling her that her father had been dead for hours. She figured car accident. She knew he'd been driving a lot, looking for work. She called her brother, Peter Camacho, Jr.
短信里告诉她，她父亲已经去世好几个小时了。她以为是车祸。她知道他为了找工作经常开车。她给哥哥小彼得·卡马乔打了电话。
I said, Peter, what is happening? What happened? And he explained that they had gone to a funeral, and he said, I never should have let Dad go to the funeral with all those vaxxed people.
我说，彼得，发生了什么？到底怎么了？他解释说他们去参加了一个葬礼，他说，我真不该让爸爸去参加有那么多接种过疫苗的人的葬礼。
Vaccinated people. Her brother believed that COVID vaccines weren't just dangerous for people who got the vaccine. Vaccinated people were dangerous to be around if you are unvaccinated, like him and his dad. They lived together. They'd been living together for years.
已接种疫苗的人。她哥哥认为新冠疫苗不仅对接种者本身有害，而且如果你像他和父亲那样没打过疫苗，接触接种过疫苗的人也很危险。他们住在一起，已经住了很多年。
And I was like, I can't even begin this argument. I'm just going to listen. And he goes, I should never have hugged-- and he named a cousin. And he said, I should never have let my dad hug-- and he named the same cousin. They're all vaxxed idiots.
我就想，我根本没法开始这场争论。我只能听着。他说，我不该让爸爸拥抱……他提了一个表亲的名字。他说，我不该让爸爸拥抱……又是同一个表亲。他们都是接种了疫苗的白痴。
So he didn't say, Dad had COVID.
所以他没说爸爸得了新冠？
No.
没有。
He's just saying-- OK.
他只是说……好吧。
Right, he just starts with, I never should have let him go to the funeral to hug vaccinated people. He said, because of all their shedding, they shed the virus. And it stopped me in my tracks. And then I just-- I was like, so what happened? He had COVID? And he said, no, no, but he was having trouble breathing. He had pneumonia.
对，他一开头就说，他不该让爸爸去葬礼拥抱接种过疫苗的人。他说因为他们会“脱落”病毒，传播病毒。这让我愣住了。然后我问，那到底发生了什么？他得了新冠吗？他说，没有，没有，但他呼吸困难，得了肺炎。
Like, Peter, all of his symptoms are COVID. You're saying he had shallow breathing. You're saying he was fatigued. You're saying he lacked the strength to even eat. At one point, he was just sort of trying to pour milk-- or not milk, sorry-- soup into the corners of his mouth and spraying him with water to get some level of hydration. And he said that his bed was covered in sweat.
我说，彼得，他所有的症状都是新冠。你说他呼吸浅，你说他疲劳，你说他虚弱到连饭都吃不下。有一次，他甚至试图往嘴边倒汤——对不起，不是奶——还得用水喷他来给他补水。他说他的床都被汗水浸透了。
And then he said, Dad would stare off, and so I'd slap him. And then he'd look at me, and that he just-- he would say, hey, Dad, are you OK? And he'd go, yeah.
然后他说，爸爸经常发呆，所以我就打他。然后他会看着我，我就会说，嘿，爸爸，你还好吗？他会说，嗯。
Until the last time, when he didn't.
直到最后一次，他再也没回应。
And he said Dad's eyes were just wide open. And I slapped him, and he was gone.
他说爸爸的眼睛睁得很大。我打了他一下，他就走了。
Rachel was trying to take all of this in, trying to get information without letting loose on her brother, who was plainly grief-struck from having just watched their father die in front of him. But he was telling her he had watched their father die in front of him for days. He didn't take him to the hospital, didn't call 911, didn't call Rachel to tell her their father was so sick he could barely speak. Then another thought hit her.
瑞秋试图消化这一切，努力在不向哥哥爆发的情况下获取信息，毕竟他亲眼目睹了父亲在面前去世，显然悲痛欲绝。但他告诉她，他眼睁睁看着父亲在他面前死了好几天。他没有送他去医院，没叫救护车，也没给瑞秋打电话告诉她父亲病得连话都说不出来。随后一个念头闪过她脑海。
I said, Peter, you've been his nurse this whole time. How do you feel? And he said, well, I mean, we both probably got sick around the same time, but I'm healthier than Dad. And I said, Peter, you understand you definitely have COVID. Can you take a deep breath? I need you to take a deep breath for me, and he did. And I go, OK, how do you feel? He goes, I'm tired. And that's when I just lost it. And I screamed at him. And I said, if you don't--
我说，彼得，这段时间你一直充当他的护士，你感觉怎么样？他说，嗯，意思是我们俩可能差不多时间病倒的，但我比爸爸健康。我说，彼得，你要明白你肯定感染了新冠。你能做个深呼吸吗？我需要你为我做个深呼吸，他照做了。我说，好，你感觉如何？他说，我很累。那一刻我彻底崩溃了。我对他吼道，如果你不……
You're his older sister.
你是他的姐姐。
Yeah, I'm his older and only sister. And I said, Peter, I can forgive you for not taking Dad to the hospital. I can find forgiveness somewhere in me. But I swear to you, if you don't go to the ER right now, I will not forgive you when you die. You are dying. I need you to go to the ER right now.
是的，我是他唯一的姐姐。我说，彼得，你可以因为没送爸爸去医院而原谅自己，我能在内心深处找到原谅你的理由。但我向你发誓，如果你现在不去急诊室，你死的时候我也不会原谅你。你在走向死亡。我需要你立刻去急诊室。
Rachel stayed on the phone with her brother, heard him get into the car, the door slam, the engine turn over. She finally relaxed a bit when she heard Peter go inside the hospital and check in. He was 44 years old, 6 foot 4, 220. Never smoked, didn't drink, lifted weights. When COVID hit, he'd been on a cleanse.
瑞秋一直保持通话，听着他上车、关门、发动引擎。当听到彼得走进医院挂号时，她终于松了口气。他今年44岁，身高6英尺4英寸（约1.93米），体重220磅（约100公斤）。从不抽烟，不喝酒，喜欢举重。新冠疫情刚开始时，他甚至在做排毒疗程。
He had health insurance through MediCal, California's Medicaid system. But Peter hadn't had a full-time job in years. He depended on his father. He didn't have his own bank account. His first text exchange with Rachel from the hospital was about money. He asked--
他有加州医疗补助计划(MediCal)的保险。但彼得已经好几年没有全职工作了。他依赖父亲，没有自己的银行账户。他从医院给瑞秋发的第一条短信就是关于钱的。他问——
How much was Jake's bill?
杰克的账单是多少？
Meaning, how much was Rachel's then-partner Jacob's medical bill when he had COVID? She texted back--
意思是，瑞秋当时的伴侣雅各布患新冠时的医药费是多少？她回复——
I said it seriously is the last thing you need to be concerned about right now. So just please-- it doesn't matter. I'm so proud of you for taking care of yourself, Peter. He said, 103 temp, oxygen levels low. I said, yep. Jacob was at 83 when I brought him in. That's really, really bad.
我说这真的是你现在最不需要操心的事情。所以请……这不重要。我为你照顾自己感到骄傲，彼得。他说，体温103华氏度（约39.4摄氏度），氧含量低。我说，是的。我送雅各布去医院时他的氧含量是83。那非常非常糟糕。
And he said, they just better not put me on a ventilator. And I said, Peter, you are a fighter. I need you to meditate on your living, on surviving this. And he says, thanks for getting me going on this. I wasn't going to get any better at home. And I said, no, you weren't. And if they want to put you on remdesivir, ask them to pair it with Olumiant. It's a game changer.
他说，他们最好别给我上呼吸机。我说，彼得，你是斗士。我需要你冥想活下去，熬过这一关。他说，谢谢你提醒我。我在家确实好不了。我说，是的，你不会好转的。如果他们想给你用瑞德西韦，要求他们配上Olumiant。那才是关键的转折点。
Remdesivir and Olumiant was the combination that doctors had given to Jacob the week before. That's how Rachel knew about it. She had just been through all this.
瑞德西韦和Olumiant是医生前一周给雅各布的组合药。瑞秋就是这么知道的。她刚刚经历过这一切。
If it isn't pneumonia yet, they need to put you on the monoclonal antibodies.
如果还不是肺炎，他们需要给你用单克隆抗体。
This is you saying all this to him.
这是你在对他说的？
I said this to him, and he said, I don't like these guys.
我对他说这些，他回答说，我不喜欢这些家伙。
Peter didn't like the guys at the hospital because they wanted to swab his nose for a PCR test to see if he had COVID. He told Rachel he thought the swab tests were a scam, that doctors got a $15,000 bonus for every swab they did that led to a positive COVID result.
彼得不喜欢医院的人，因为他们想给他做PCR鼻拭子测试来确定是否得了新冠。他告诉瑞秋，他认为拭子检测是个骗局，医生每做一次导致新冠阳性的检测就能拿到1.5万美元的奖金。
I said, I love you, Peter. Let them help you get better. He said, I love you, too. Minutes later, positive for COVID.
我说，彼得，我爱你。让他们帮你变好。他说，我也爱你。几分钟后，检测结果呈阳性。
Within three days, to Rachel's great surprise and relief, Peter told her he was on the mend. He went home to rest, and she made plans to go out to Santa Ana, California, where he lived and where the two of them had grown up. Peter asked Rachel a couple of times after he left the hospital whether their father's cause of death had been identified yet. She said COVID, even though she hadn't seen the death certificate, because it seemed obvious to her. And she turned out to be right.
三天之内，令瑞秋极其惊讶和宽慰的是，彼得告诉她他正在好转。他回家休息了，她计划去他居住的加州圣安娜，那是他们成长的地方。彼得离开医院后问过瑞秋几次父亲的死因是否确定了。虽然她没见过死亡证明，但她说是因为新冠，因为这显而易见。结果证明她是正确的。
When Rachel got to Santa Ana, along with one of her older kids, Peter asked them over the phone not to come in the house. Said he still felt too vulnerable because they were vaccinated. He believed, again, that vaccines make people shed the virus, and therefore, vaccinated people are especially dangerous to be around for the unvaccinated.
当瑞秋带着她的大孩子到达圣安娜时，彼得在电话里请求她们不要进屋。他说他感觉自己依然脆弱，因为她们接种过疫苗。他依然认为疫苗会让人们“脱落”病毒，因此，接种过疫苗的人对未接种者来说格外危险。
Rachel decided to give him some time. They would see him before they left. They could do it outside in masks in the backyard. She didn't push. He sounded tired. She wasn't surprised. After she'd had COVID, she'd barely been able to open a jar for a week. Rachel kept checking in via text and phone calls. She was handling the paperwork and details of their father's death. She was dropping off food at the front door. Food, logistics, love.
瑞秋决定给他一点时间。她们在离开前会见到他。可以在后院戴着口罩在户外见面。她没有强求。他的声音听起来很累。她并不意外。她自己感染新冠后，有一周时间连个罐子都拧不开。瑞秋不断通过短信和电话跟进。她在处理父亲去世的文件和细节。她会把食物放在前门。食物、后勤、关怀。
You hungry? Can I pick you up anything? I'm close. I'm two blocks away. He says, can't think of anything right now. Those guys ever contact you? I say, I called yesterday. They said they're super busy and the paperwork was sent to the crematorium on Thursday.
你饿吗？要不要我帮你带点什么？我就在附近，隔两个街区。他说，现在什么都不想吃。那些人联系你了吗？我说，我昨天打过电话。他们说非常忙，文件周四已经送到火葬场了。
That's one of their last texts. Peter died a week after Rachel got to Santa Ana. She never saw him. A long-time neighbor found him. Rachel learned from the coroner that her brother had not made a quick, remarkable recovery and been discharged from the hospital to go rest at home, as she had believed. He had checked himself out of the hospital after 2 and 1/2 days against medical advice.
这是他们最后几条短信之一。彼得在瑞秋到达圣安娜一周后去世了。她从没见到他。一位老邻居发现了他的遗体。瑞秋从验尸官那里得知，她的哥哥并没有像她以为的那样，在医院实现了快速、显著的康复并出院回家休息。他在住院两天半后违背医嘱自己办理了出院。
I was stunned. I mean, what it means is that he was lying to me. He knew what to say. He knew what to hide. I mean, I was-- I was floating through my days. It felt like my brain had been wiped.
我惊呆了。这意味着他在骗我。他知道该说什么。他知道该隐藏什么。我感觉自己像在云里飘，大脑一片空白。
Rachel was dumbfounded by how much she didn't know about her father's and brother's last month of being alive. Everything was gone. All the answers she'd put off trying to get from her brother about why he hadn't asked for help for their father-- gone. Her brother's recovery-- fake, some kind of performance. She had no idea what he'd been thinking as he was fading away, what he'd been doing, instead of telling her the truth. And then Rachel made a discovery-- a record of Peter's final days. And she found out exactly what happened.
瑞秋对她对父亲和哥哥生命的最后一个月一无所知感到震惊。一切都没了。她推迟想要从哥哥那里得到的关于为何不为父亲寻求帮助的答案——全都消失了。哥哥的康复——是假的，只是一场表演。她根本不知道他在逐渐衰弱时在想什么，不知道他在没告诉她真相时都在做些什么。然后瑞秋有了一个发现——一份关于彼得最后日子的记录。她终于知道了到底发生了什么。
Part One, Black Box. COVID caught us while we were busy. Each person it found, and each family, was in the midst of their specific unfinished business, their pre-existing fault lines and disconnections. The fault lines are why I'm here. This is a story about a family and what COVID did to them, what it destroyed, but also what it revealed.
第一部分，黑匣子。新冠在我们需要忙碌时抓住了我们。每一个被它找到的人、每一个家庭，都正处于各自未完成的生活琐事、预先存在的裂痕和断裂之中。这些裂痕就是我在这里的原因。这是一个关于一个家庭以及新冠对他们所做的一切的故事，它摧毁了什么，但也揭示了什么。
Rachel lived thousands of miles away from her father and brother, and she was used to stretches of relative silence with them. But those quieter periods were always part of a rhythm that swung back. Even an angry silence was never permanent. Now, the fact that she didn't have any idea what happened at the end, Rachel was tormented by this not knowing. The pain propelled her. She wasn't quiet with grief. She was vibrating with it. She had questions.
瑞秋与父亲和哥哥相隔数千英里，她习惯了与他们保持相对沉默的状态。但那些平静的时期总是某种循环的一部分。即便是愤怒的沉默也从不是永久的。现在，由于对结局一无所知，瑞秋被这种未知所折磨。痛苦驱使着她。她并没有在悲伤中保持安静，她为之颤抖。她有很多疑问。
The first person she called after talking to the coroner was her and Peter's cousin. Rachel and her brother were only a year and a half apart, and the cousin was right around the same age, mid-40s. The three of them had grown up playing together. Her cousin seemed just as baffled as she was by Peter's death, by the fact that he left the hospital against medical advice.
她在与验尸官谈话后打给的第一个人是她和彼得的表亲。瑞秋和哥哥只差一岁半，表亲年龄也差不多，四十出头。三人从小一起长大。表亲看起来和她一样对彼得的死感到困惑，对彼得违背医嘱离开医院的事感到不可思议。
She asked him a terrible question the coroner had asked her. Any chance this was intentional? Had her brother been suicidal? Rachel didn't think so, but she also felt like, what the hell do I know? She says her cousin said, no way. No way. Peter wanted to live. At the house where Peter and her father had lived, Rachel gathered up old photos and looked through them.
她问了一个验尸官曾问过她的可怕问题：这有可能是故意的吗？她哥哥自杀了吗？瑞秋不这么认为，但她又觉得，我到底知道什么？她说表亲回答说，绝不可能。彼得想活下去。在彼得和父亲居住的房子里，瑞秋收集了一些旧照片浏览着。
These are all great photos, and I want these, but I wonder if they had any photos of themselves. I don't even know what they looked like in the final years. I don't know. And so I started charging their phones. And then I heard, bloop, bloop, bloop, bloop, bloop, like message, message, message. And I'm like, oh, god, I didn't even think about there's people checking in on my brother. And then I just started reading.
这些照片都很棒，我想要这些，但我不知道他们是否有自己的照片。我甚至不知道他们最后几年长什么样。我不知道。于是我开始给他们的手机充电。然后我听到“噗、噗、噗、噗、噗”的声音，全是信息提示。我就想，噢天哪，我都没考虑到有人在关注我哥哥。然后我就开始读了。
Rachel looked at a text from the cousin she just talked to. His last text to Peter on the day Peter died, he said, "Yo, Jax, please answer me, man."
瑞秋看到了一条来自刚才谈话的那个表亲的短信。彼得去世当天表亲发给他的最后一条短信说：“嘿，杰克斯，求你回我一下，老兄。”
And then before that are several TikTok links. And I was like, ugh, what are these? And then I don't have the app. I don't really know how to operate it, I'll be honest. I'm not interested in it. And then I just scrolled up. And I just couldn't help, but just be invested in their conversation.
在那之前还有几个TikTok链接。我就想，呃，这些是什么？我没装这个软件。坦白说，我不知道怎么操作。我不感兴趣。但我还是向上翻了翻。我情不自禁地投入到他们的对话中。
Rachel kept scrolling up and up and up through the texts between Peter and their cousin until she was back in October, when Peter was still alive and was texting with their cousin about what to do about Rachel and Peter's dad, who was so sick with COVID at that point, he was having trouble lifting his arms. The cousin guesses that Peter's father might have myocarditis. Peter thinks maybe it's a bacterial infection of some kind.
瑞秋在彼得和表亲的短信记录里不断向上翻，一直翻到10月份。当时彼得还活着，正在和表亲讨论如何处理瑞秋和彼得的父亲，父亲当时新冠病得很重，胳膊都抬不起来了。表亲推测父亲可能得了心肌炎。彼得认为可能是某种细菌感染。
The night before Peter's father dies of COVID, Peter texts his cousin and says, "Do you or your mom or anyone in your house have antibiotics?" A minute later, the cousin writes back, "No," and asks Peter, "How are you feeling?"
在彼得的父亲因新冠去世的前一晚，彼得给表亲发短信说：“你、你妈或者你们家其他人有抗生素吗？”一分钟后，表亲回复“没有”，并问彼得：“你感觉怎么样？”
Peter, 20 minutes later-- "Definitely not well yet. A fever that keeps springing back to 103, agitating dry cough, and the squirts again. My dad has the same cough, only 100 temperature, and is shallow breathing, pretty fast. I'm thinking the fever keeps coming back because it might be a bacterial thing. The cough is [BLEEP] horrible--" I'm beeping that because he wrote "F" and then a bunch of asterisks. "The cough is [BLEEP] horrible because it waits till we lay down to go to sleep, and it becomes very itchy. And we can't go to sleep because of it. We end up coughing all night. So we're both very sleep deprived."
20分钟后彼得说：“绝对还不好。发烧又回到了103度，干咳让人抓狂，又拉肚子了。我爸有同样的咳嗽，只是体温100度，呼吸急促，非常快。我在想发烧反复是因为可能是细菌感染。咳嗽简直[哔——]恐怖。”我消音了，因为他写的是“F”开头后面加了一串星号。“咳嗽简直[哔——]恐怖，因为它总在我们要躺下睡觉时发作，变得非常痒。我们因为这个没法入睡。我们整晚都在咳嗽。所以我们俩都极度睡眠不足。”
Cousin-- "Fuck, that's bad." Cousin, a few minutes later-- "OK, so tomorrow, I'm going to bring you guys [BLEEP]. I'm going to [BLEEP] you guys." Peter-- "Oh, man, bring it." Cousin-- "I will. I just got to run to the store tomorrow morning and buy ingredients and make it. I also have an immunity kit that I just ordered from my old job. Keeping it, like, behind glass in case of emergencies. It's time to break the glass." Peter-- "Sounds good to me. I'll tell Pops."
表亲：“该死，太糟糕了。”几分钟后表亲写道：“好了，明天我给你们带[哔——]过去。我给你们[哔——]。”彼得：“噢，老兄，带过来吧。”表亲：“我会的。明天早上我要跑趟商店买点原料做。我还有一套从旧公司订的免疫套装。一直像珍宝一样锁在柜子里，以备不时之需。现在是时候启用它了。”彼得：“听起来不错。我会告诉老爸。”
15 minutes later, Peter texts about him and his dad-- "We were already detoxing anyway two weeks prior, so I thought our bodies were just following through on its own. I mean, we gave up the bad food we were eating every day, even coffee. Coffee, dude. Yes, even that creamer. And then this [BLEEP] comes on. It's like we try to do it right, and then we get [BLEEP]." Cousin-- "Damn it, you guys were too clean."
15分钟后，彼得发短信谈论他和父亲：“反正我们两周前已经在排毒了，所以我以为我们的身体能自己扛过去。我的意思是，我们放弃了每天吃的垃圾食品，甚至咖啡。咖啡啊，伙计。连奶精都戒了。结果这个[哔——]来了。好像我们试着做得正确，然后我们被[哔——]了。”表亲：“该死，你们太干净了。”
Rachel saw, over the course of her father's last day, Peter describing their dad hallucinating, coughing, grunting, losing control of his bladder and bowels, Peter giving him vitamins and probiotics. The cousin dropped off a final round of soup on the porch in the afternoon.
瑞秋看到，在她父亲生命的最后一天，彼得描述了父亲产生幻觉、咳嗽、咕哝、失去大小便控制，彼得给他喂维生素和益生菌的过程。表亲在下午最后一次把汤放在了门廊。
Seeing how her father's death had unfolded was awful, how he'd suffered. But Rachel also read those texts, and everything Peter and her cousin wrote going forward with the helpless awareness of somebody watching a Greek tragedy, knowing what the characters don't, all the horror that's to come.
目睹父亲的去世过程是痛苦的，他受尽折磨。但瑞秋读着这些短信，读着彼得和表亲之后写的一切，带着那种观看希腊悲剧般的无力感——因为她知道那些角色所不知道的事情，知道未来即将发生的所有恐怖。
It's like the black box after a plane crash. It's like hearing ghosts speak of themselves. I mean, I just responded with absolute rage and heartbreak.
就像飞机坠毁后的黑匣子。就像听着幽灵在诉说自己的故事。我只能用绝对的愤怒和心碎来回应。
She saw the text exchange between her brother and cousin at the moment her father died. Peter-- "I believe he's taken his final breaths." And then a minute later-- "He's gone." Cousin-- "What? Peter, what?" Peter-- "I seriously don't know what to do now."
她看到了父亲去世时哥哥和表亲的短信记录。彼得：“我相信他已经呼出了最后一口气。”一分钟后——“他走了。”表亲：“什么？彼得，你说什么？”彼得：“我现在真的不知道该怎么办了。”
This is when Rachel saw herself enter the conversation, when her brother texted her that their father was gone. She saw in the texts how the shock of their father's death had opened up a window of opportunity with Peter. And in that window, Peter had texted her, and she'd convinced him to go to the hospital. Or, as he put it in a text to the cousin--
这时瑞秋看到自己介入了对话，当时哥哥发短信告诉她父亲走了。她在短信里看到，父亲去世的冲击如何为她与彼得的沟通打开了一扇窗。在那个窗口期，彼得发短信给她，她劝服了他去医院。或者，正如他在发给表亲的短信里所说——
"Rachel demanded that I go to the ER, so I'm going to the ER."
“瑞秋要求我去急诊室，所以我现在去急诊室。”
Their cousin texted back-- "Keep me posted."
表亲回复：“随时告诉我情况。”
That was when I understood that there were dual conversations being had, and that one was my attempt at saving my brother's life, and the other one was my cousin's version of an attempt at saving my brother's life.
那时我才明白，当时存在着双重对话，一个是我想挽救哥哥生命的尝试，另一个是表亲试图挽救哥哥生命的尝试。
Rachel and Peter's cousin didn't respond to my texts, letter, and phone message requesting an interview with him. I'm not naming him because of that, and because I don't want strangers harassing him over this story. Rachel hasn't spoken to him since she found the texts between him and her brother, and he hasn't contacted her.
瑞秋和彼得的表亲没有回应我的面试请求。我不提他的名字是因为这个，也是因为我不想让陌生人因为这个故事骚扰他。瑞秋自发现那些短信后就没再跟他说话，他也从没联系过她。
Peter, in these texts back and forth with each of them, is clearly scared for his life. And I don't know what people do in countries that have a functioning healthcare system, but in the United States, a lot of us, maybe most of us, seek out advice from friends and family in the midst of a health crisis. The friends and family guidance is often supplemented by the internet, and then we're faced with a messy pile of anecdotes, jargon, and sales pitches to sift through.
彼得在与他们两人的往返短信中，显然为自己的生命感到害怕。我不知道在拥有完善医疗系统的国家人们会怎么做，但在美国，我们中的很多人，可能绝大多数人，在健康危机中会向亲友寻求建议。这种建议往往会辅以互联网上的信息，然后我们面对的是一堆混乱的轶事、行话和推销内容，需要费心甄别。
That messy pile may be all a person has if they don't have a primary care doctor. Peter didn't. But he did live close enough to a decent hospital that he was able to make it in time to be offered possibly life saving care, at which point he began to worry. Can I afford this?
如果一个人没有初级保健医生，这堆混乱的信息可能就是他所拥有的一切。彼得没有。但他住得离一家还不错的医院够近，本可以及时获得挽救生命的机会，而就在那时他开始担忧：我付得起钱吗？
Peter's mistrust of the medical system revolved around money. In his texts with his cousin, even before he and his father got sick, Peter kept returning to the idea that he didn't believe in the COVID tests and treatments because people were getting rich from them. He believed there was a government plan that gave hospitals and doctors financial incentives to kill people and blame COVID.
彼得对医疗系统的不信任源于金钱。在与表亲的短信中，甚至在父子俩生病前，彼得就一直反复提到他不相信新冠检测和治疗，因为有人从中获利。他相信政府有一个计划，给医院和医生经济刺激去害死人，然后归咎于新冠。
Peter was afraid of the wrong things with COVID. He was just incorrect. But the overall idea that the US medical system is shaped by profit-seeking that is often at odds with good patient care, that's a fact. No one in America is wrong to be afraid of medical bills. In light of that reality and in light of Peter's earlier texts, it's a sign of just how scared he was when he texts Rachel from the hospital and says--
彼得对新冠害怕的东西搞错了。他完全弄错了。但关于美国医疗系统被追逐利润所左右，且往往与良好的病人护理相冲突的总体看法，这却是一个事实。在美国，没有人有错去害怕巨额账单。鉴于这种现实，也考虑到彼得之前的短信，他从医院给瑞秋发短信时表现出的那种恐惧是显而易见的——
"Thanks for getting me going on this. I wasn't going to get any better at home."
“谢谢你让我去医院。我在家确实好不了。”
And it was hard for Rachel to accept, as she was reading through the texts, that only 40 minutes after he wrote that to her, when he finds out the hospital will be giving him a nasal swab, Peter's resolve starts to falter. And so Peter texted their cousin-- "They PCR'd me," cringe emoji. "Too sick to get up and leave." No response from the cousin. An hour later, Rachel texts Peter--
而对瑞秋来说，读着短信很难接受的是，就在他给她发完这些信息的40分钟后，当他得知医院要给他做鼻拭子时，彼得的决心开始动摇了。于是彼得给表亲发短信：“他们给我做PCR了”，还配了个尴尬表情。“太虚弱了，没法起来离开。”表亲没有回应。一小时后，瑞秋给彼得发短信——
"I love you, Peter. Let them help you get better."
“彼得，我爱你。让他们帮你变好。”
Peter writes back-- "I love you, too." An hour later, the cousin texts him-- "Did the test come back yet?" Peter-- "Positive, of course." Peter texts the cousin that he's just been given some steroids in his IV. It was an anti-inflammatory, dexamethasone-- an inexpensive generic, for anyone counting at home.
彼得回复：“我也爱你。”一小时后，表亲发短信问：“测试结果出来了吗？”彼得：“不出所料，阳性。”彼得发短信告诉表亲，他刚在静脉输液里被注射了某种类固醇。那是地塞米松——一种便宜的仿制药，任何懂点行情的人都知道。
A month earlier, before Peter's father had even gotten sick, the cousin had texted Peter that, quote, "hospitals get a 20% bonus for administering Fauci's poison, remdesivir." Now, the cousin texts Peter-- "What was the steroid called?" And a couple of minutes later-- "OK, I just read remdesivir is not a steroid. Phew." Peter texts the cousin an hour later, saying, "Rachel said, 'If they want to put you on remdesivir, ask them to pair it with Olumiant. It's a game changer.'" No response from the cousin.
一个月前，在彼得的父亲生病前，表亲曾给彼得发短信说，“医院为使用福奇的毒药瑞德西韦可获得20%的奖金。”现在，表亲给彼得发短信问：“那个类固醇叫什么名字？”几分钟后——“噢，我刚读到瑞德西韦不是类固醇。呼。”彼得一小时后给表亲发短信说：“瑞秋说，‘如果他们想给你用瑞德西韦，要求他们配上Olumiant。那才是关键的转折点。’”表亲没有回应。
The cousin, 2 and 1/2 hours later-- "Fuck that. Do not take remdesivir. 54% chance it'll shut down your kidneys." Several hours later, Peter textes the cousin-- "They finally brought in a bag of remdesivir, and I said, I'll hold off on that. And he said, OK, that's fine. I had no problem with the nurse's assistants and the nurse, but as soon as the doctor comes and makes a decision, you know it's the [BLEEP] ones."
表亲在两个半小时后回复：“滚开。别用瑞德西韦。有54%的几率会造成肾衰竭。”几小时后，彼得发短信给表亲：“他们终于拿了一袋瑞德西韦来，我说，我先不用那个。他说，好吧，没关系。护士助理和护士没问题，但一旦医生来做决定，你知道那肯定是那些[哔——]中的一个。”
The cousin a minute later-- "No, no, no remdesivir." Peter texts him a photo of an IV bag. The cousin asks, "They're giving it to you?" Peter-- "No, I told them I'll pass." The cousin-- '"OK. I know you're tired, but keep an eye on those fuckers. Watch everything they're putting in those lines."
表亲一分钟后回复：“不，不，绝对不用瑞德西韦。”彼得发给表亲一张静脉输液袋的照片。表亲问：“他们正在给你输吗？”彼得：“没有，我告诉他们我不用。”表亲：“好吧。我知道你很累，但盯着那些混蛋。看好他们往输液管里加的一切。”
I'd offer him advice, and I'd see him go to our cousin to get the second opinion, you know? And he would just always derail those efforts. It's just the most unfathomable, absurd conversation to watch happen.
我会提供建议，然后眼睁睁看他去找表亲寻求所谓的“第二意见”。而他总是会搞砸那些努力。眼睁睁看着这一切发生，对话荒谬得让人无法理解。
Peter texts the cousin a photo of his dad at that family funeral he told Rachel about. Their dad is hugging a relative who was vaccinated, as he'd mentioned to Rachel. He captions the photo, "the day my dad was killed." The next morning, Peter texts the cousin-- "Temp finally down, 98.8. Still on oxygen because my oxygen levels are weak." The cousin-- "I'm glad you're starting to improve. The sooner, the better. They won't have a chance to kill you."
彼得给表亲发了一张父亲在那个家庭葬礼上的照片。父亲拥抱了一位接种过疫苗的亲戚，正如他之前跟瑞秋提到的。他给照片加了标题：“我爸爸被杀的那天。”第二天早上，彼得给表亲发短信：“体温终于降到98.8度了。还在吸氧，因为血氧水平很弱。”表亲：“很高兴你开始好转。越快越好。他们就没机会杀你了。”
Again, the cousin didn't respond to my interview requests. One of the things I know about the cousin, the very little I know from reading the full thread of his texts, is that he's a father. Two of the family members who live with him are in their 70s, and he worries about their health.
再次说明，表亲没有回应我的采访请求。我对他了解的一点点信息是，从通读他短信的全过程来看，他是个父亲。住在他家里的两个家庭成员已经70多岁了，他很担心他们的健康。
He's a man with multiple heavy responsibilities, who is also up late and early for weeks, worrying about his cousin Peter, checking on him. I also know from Rachel that about 10 years ago, the cousin lost another cousin, Jennifer, who was like a little sister to him after she went to the hospital.
他是一个肩负多重沉重责任的男人，连续数周熬夜早起，担心着表弟彼得，关照着他。我还从瑞秋那里得知，大约10年前，表亲失去了另一个像亲妹妹一样的表亲詹妮弗，她在去医院后去世了。
Unexpected. It didn't make sense. She was the youngest of the four of us cousins. And her bladder had been nicked during a cesarean. And she had sepsis. And she was young and had these babies, and then she died.
太意外了。这说不通。她是四个表亲里最小的。她在剖腹产时膀胱被划破了，得了败血症。她还那么年轻，孩子那么小，然后就死了。
And the whole family was crushed, Rachel and Peter, too. Jennifer was 32 years old, and Rachel says that for Peter, this medical error was one searing event in a lifetime of smaller moments that gradually transformed him from someone who had never trusted authority figures in general and didn't go to doctors-- he believed he could take better care of himself with exercise and nutrition than some doctor-- to someone who saw doctors and hospitals as dangerous, and later, as actively seeking to deceive and harm and even kill people for their own gain.
整个家庭都崩溃了，瑞秋和彼得也是。詹妮弗当时32岁。瑞秋说，对彼得来说，这起医疗事故是他一生中众多小事件中刻骨铭心的一次。它让他逐渐从一个不信任权威、不去医院的人（他认为通过锻炼和营养能比医生照顾得更好），转变成一个认为医生和医院很危险的人，后来甚至认为他们为了自身利益，主动欺骗、伤害甚至杀害他人。
The day before he leaves the hospital, Peter texts the cousin-- "The doctor finally came down and asked why I won't take remdesivir. And he said, you're not vaccinated? And I said, that's correct. He said that's the only treatment we have for COVID and that my lungs are going to deteriorate with the oxygen they keep ordering for me if I don't take the remdesivir. I said I'll think about it. And he said OK and left." Remdesivir might have reduced Peter's need for oxygen. Concentrated oxygen can harm someone's lungs over time, especially if they've been damaged by, for instance, COVID.
在彼得离开医院的前一天，他给表亲发短信：“医生终于下来问我为什么不肯用瑞德西韦。他说，你没打疫苗吗？我说，是的。他说那是我们治疗新冠的唯一方法，如果我不服用瑞德西韦，他们一直给我订的氧气会让我肺部恶化。我说我会考虑的。他说好吧就走了。”瑞德西韦可能减少了彼得对氧气的需求。高浓度氧气长时间使用可能会损害肺部，尤其是肺部如果已经受损（例如感染了新冠）。
The cousin texts back a few minutes later-- "Bull [BLEEP]. That remdesivir is going to deteriorate your organs, especially your kidneys. You've been pumping ibuprofen all week. He's just trying to scare you so he can get his 20% bonus for using remdesivir. That same doctor will tell you the vaccine is good for you, which makes no sense because now that you're confirmed that you have COVID and you're recovering, it seems like you'll have natural immunity for life. You won't need boosters. Just pray your oxygen level improves so you can get the hell out of there."
表亲几分钟后回复：“胡说[哔——]。瑞德西韦会损害你的器官，尤其是肾脏。你已经输了一周的布洛芬了。他只是想吓唬你，这样他就能拿到用瑞德西韦的20%奖金。同一个医生会告诉你疫苗对你有好处，这根本说不通，因为现在确认你感染了新冠并且正在康复，看来你将获得终身自然免疫力。你不需要加强针。祈祷你的血氧水平提升，这样你就能从那儿滚出来了。”
As Rachel is reading the texts, she keeps glimpsing these moments here and there over the last weeks of Peter's life when Peter acknowledges, this is COVID. But the idea of COVID is like a balloon that can't stay aloft. Peter texts a bit later-- "All I have to do is jog a little. I'll get my oxygen back up. Sitting in a hospital bed isn't doing anything, oxygen-wise." The cousin-- "Do the turmeric and mint leaf lung inhaling exercises at home. Yeah, you're not going to continue to deteriorate. He's a fucking liar."
当瑞秋读这些短信时，她不断在彼得最后几周的生活中瞥见他承认“这是新冠”的时刻。但“新冠”这个概念就像一个无法保持高度的气球。彼得过了一会发短信：“我只需要慢跑一下。血氧就能恢复。坐在医院病床上什么都没用。”表亲：“在家做姜黄和薄荷叶肺部吸入练习。是的，你不会继续恶化的。他是个该死的骗子。”
A few minutes later, Rachel texts Peter, and they go back and forth about his oxygen levels and whether he has enough energy to eat and if he has a phone charger. Rachel asks him if he's heard an estimated timeline for them to discharge him. Peter texts, "They made it sound like soon, possibly today or tomorrow." Rachel--
几分钟后，瑞秋给彼得发短信，他们来回讨论他的血氧水平、是否还有力气进食以及是否有手机充电器。瑞秋问他是否听说医院预计的出院时间。彼得回：“他们听起来好像很快，可能是今天或明天。”瑞秋——
"Holy shit. OK."
“天哪。好吧。”
I've talked to Rachel a bunch of times, and from what I've seen, she doesn't like to let untrue things slide. She really doesn't like it. But in her texts with Peter, I can see her trying hard to be careful with him, trying to encourage him, support him, tell him what she thinks is important in her big sister way, but not argue with him.
我和瑞秋谈过很多次，据我观察，她不喜欢让不真实的事情随风而去。她真的很厌恶这一点。但在与彼得的短信中，我能看出她努力克制自己，试着鼓励他、支持他，以大姐的方式告诉她认为重要的事情，但不去跟他争论。
This deliberate withholding of her full forcefulness is part of their relationship. Rachel feeling protective of Peter is built into her earliest memories. He's been physically bigger since he was 15, but she's always been tougher.
这种刻意的克制是他们关系的一部分。瑞秋保护彼得的感觉植根于她最早的记忆中。他从15岁起就比她块头大，但她一直比他更强硬。
Peter, later that afternoon, texts with the cousin and again brings up the idea that maybe this might be COVID. Peter-- "Can you look up safe treatments for COVID?" The cousin writes back-- "Hang in there. I'm checking frantically."
那天下午晚些时候，彼得在与表亲发短信时再次提到了这可能是新冠。“你能帮我查查新冠的安全治疗方案吗？”表亲写道：“坚持住。我正在疯狂核对。”
And then the cousin texts-- "Monoclonal antibodies, convalescent plasma, or ivermectin. The first two options are usually only given while in the ER. Once you're admitted, the protocol changes to remdesivir. They only treat the vaccinated with ivermectin, so that way, when they recover, they can say, see? The vaccine kept you from dying. Motherfuckers."
然后表亲发短信：“单克隆抗体、康复期血浆或伊维菌素。前两个选项通常只在急诊室提供。一旦入院，协议就变成瑞德西韦。他们只给接种过疫苗的人用伊维菌素，这样等他们康复时，他们就可以说，看？疫苗救了你的命。混蛋们。”
The evidence about ivermectin is now overwhelming. It's not effective as either protection against COVID or treatment of it. And while we're here, natural immunity for life against COVID is not a thing. And vaccines don't cause people to shed the virus.
现在关于伊维菌素的证据已经压倒性地证明，它作为预防或治疗新冠均无效。而且顺便说一句，对新冠的“终身自然免疫”是不存在的。疫苗也不会导致人们“脱落”病毒。
But let's talk briefly about remdesivir. I spoke with a few doctors who've been treating COVID patients since the beginning in clinics and hospitals. They were unanimous. Remdesivir has revealed itself to be not actually a very effective treatment against COVID. It isn't harmful in all the ways Peter's cousin kept saying it was. That was remdesivir's strength. It was generally safe.
但我们简单谈谈瑞德西韦。我和几位从一开始就在诊所和医院治疗新冠病人的医生谈过。他们众口一词。瑞德西韦事实证明并不是一种对抗新冠的非常有效的治疗方法。它并不像彼得表亲所说的那样在各方面都有害。那是瑞德西韦的强项，它通常是安全的。
Studies did confirm its modest usefulness in some patients, but as one doctor put it, "Remdesivir was a tool we used because we had so few tools." Even the drug combo Rachel recommended-- remdesivir plus Olumiant-- one careful study showed patients who got the combo were less likely to die than those who got remdesivir alone, but only about 3% less likely to die.
研究证实了它在某些患者中有些许作用，但正如一位医生所言：“瑞德西韦是我们使用的工具，因为我们拥有的工具太少了。”即使是瑞秋推荐的药方——瑞德西韦加Olumiant——一项谨慎的研究显示，接受这种组合的患者死亡率确实低于仅接受瑞德西韦治疗的患者，但死亡率仅降低了约3%。
For an advanced, severe case of COVID, there is no consistent game changer. So the medicine of COVID has been genuinely confusing. We can't know if Peter would have survived, even if he did stay at the hospital. But it was probably his best shot.
对于严重的新冠病例，目前并没有一致有效的“转折点”。所以新冠的药物治疗确实令人困惑。我们无法知道即便留在医院彼得是否能幸存，但那可能是他最好的机会。
Two doctors I spoke with told me how important it was, in their experience, to just let a patient talk if they were reluctant to get treatment for anything. Don't try to convince them. Just ask them, what has this been like for you? Then listen. But the doctors were also frank about how often with COVID they didn't have time for that conversation, or energy.
我采访的两位医生告诉我，在他们的经验中，如果病人对任何治疗感到犹豫，让他们说话是多么重要。不要试图说服他们。只要问他们，这对你来说是什么样的经历？然后倾听。但医生们也坦言，在新冠疫情中，他们经常没有时间或精力进行那种谈话。
Before COVID, they'd seen plenty of people who were afraid to be hospitalized, who didn't want specific treatments. But with COVID, those conversations were different. People weren't just reluctant. Many were hostile. Some got aggressive. One doctor said she had the experience over and over of patients she'd known for years seeing her in a mask and instantly distrusting her.
新冠之前，他们见过很多害怕住院、不想要特定治疗的人。但新冠之后，那些对话变了。人们不仅仅是犹豫。许多人带有敌意。有些人变得具有攻击性。一位医生说，她反复经历过她认识多年的病人见到戴口罩的她，立刻对她产生怀疑的情况。
The doctors both said that simply asking if a person was vaccinated would often stop the conversation cold. And each person's reasons for not wanting a particular COVID treatment were bespoke-- their own tightly held bundle of beliefs and fears that were extra resistant to change. A doctor might be able to tease out and address the contents of that bundle fast enough to help the person, or they might not. Anyway, we know what happened this time.
两位医生都表示，仅仅询问一个人是否接种过疫苗，往往就会让对话僵住。每个人不想要特定新冠治疗的理由都是定制的——他们内心紧紧包裹着一团信念和恐惧，对改变特别有抵抗力。医生也许能足够快地梳理并解决这团心结从而帮助病人，也许不能。总之，我们知道这次发生了什么。
When Rachel started reading through her brother's texts, she knew he had left the hospital against medical advice. She found that out from the coroner, but she didn't know how it happened. Now she saw. Peter texts his cousin at 3:30 in the morning--
当瑞秋开始通读哥哥的短信时，她知道他是违背医嘱离开医院的。她是从验尸官那里知道的，但不知道具体怎么发生的。现在她看到了。彼得在凌晨3:30给表亲发短信——
"I'm starting to wonder if they're ever going to let me out." And my cousin says, "They have to release you upon request." My brother says, "I so hope that's true." And then my cousin sends him discharge against medical advice screencap from verywellhealth.com that states a discharge against medical advice, usually just called an AMA, requires that you sign a form agreeing that you wish to leave, but that your physician thinks it's a bad clinical choice for you to go.
“我开始怀疑他们是否打算让我出院。”表亲说：“他们必须应你的要求让你出院。”我哥哥说：“我真心希望那是真的。”然后表亲给他发了一个来自verywellhealth.com关于违背医嘱出院的截图，说明违背医嘱出院（通常简称AMA）需要你签署一份表格，同意你想离开，但你的医生认为这是糟糕的临床选择。
And he says, "Legally, they can't keep you there. That's considered false imprisonment." And my brother responds half an hour later, "How should I say it?" Quote, "I need to be discharged?" unquote. And my cousin says, "Are they currently giving you any medications?" My brother-- "Nothing yet today. Actually, all they ever gave me were steroids and antibiotics." My cousin-- "OK, do you have an IV drip?" Peter-- "No, just had me on oxygen."
表亲说：“从法律上讲，他们不能留你在那儿。那被视为非法监禁。”我哥哥半小时后回复：“我该怎么说？”“我需要出院？”表亲说：“他们目前在给你用任何药物吗？”我哥哥：“今天还没。其实他们给我的只有类固醇和抗生素。”表亲：“好了，你有静脉滴注吗？”彼得：“没有，只是让我吸氧。”
My cousin-- "Hmm, is your O2 still at about or above 95?" My brother-- "It's off right now. I was around 94. All I know is I'm not getting any better in here." So he says to me, thank you for convincing me to be here. I wasn't going to get any better at home. And tells my cousin, I'm not going to get any better. I'm not getting any better in here, in the hospital. My cousin-- "How does your chest feel?" Peter-- "It feels better than it did when I first came in," which is a sign of the treatment working.
表亲：“嗯，你的血氧还在95左右或以上吗？”我哥哥：“现在关了。我在94左右。我只知道我在医院里一点都没变好。”所以他对我这么说：感谢你劝我来医院。我在家确实好不了。然后他告诉表亲，我不会变好的。我在医院里一点都没变好。表亲：“你胸口感觉如何？”彼得：“感觉比我刚来时好些了，”这本是治疗生效的信号。
That last part isn't in the text. It was Rachel venting her frustration as she was reading through all this again. She could barely contain her rage. By the end of this next part, she was sneering.
后面那段不在短信里。那是瑞秋在再次阅读这一切时表达出的沮丧。她几乎无法抑制愤怒。到接下来这一段结束时，她在冷笑。
My cousin-- "Yeah, and the fact that they gave you antibiotics, that means, again, it was bacterial pneumonia, not viral. And the steroid helps with the inflammation. That's why the fever went down. And your lungs' irritation went down as well. Now it's just a matter of getting over the cough, which is going to linger for a few weeks, but you can probably handle that with a cough syrup because all they ever gave me was antibiotics and a prescription for a strong cough syrup."
表亲：“是的，既然他们给你用了抗生素，那说明这又是细菌性肺炎，不是病毒性的。类固醇有助于消炎。这就是发烧退下来的原因。你肺部的刺激也减轻了。现在只是需要处理咳嗽的问题，这会持续几周，但你可能可以用止咳糖浆处理，因为他们给我用的也只有抗生素和一张强效止咳糖浆的处方。”
Two minutes after-- "I believe you're out of danger now. Fuck their protocol. It's time to get probiotics back into your body."
两分钟后——“我相信你脱离危险了。去他们的程序。现在是让益生菌回到你体内的时候了。”
From the time Peter left the hospital, he lived another two weeks. All that time, Rachel was in a fog of coming to terms with their father's death. And she thought her brother was recovering, like most people who get COVID do.
从彼得离开医院算起，他又活了两周。在那段时间里，瑞秋沉浸在接受父亲去世事实的迷雾中。她以为哥哥正在康复，就像大多数感染新冠的人一样。
But Peter was texting with their cousin about his blood oxygen level. A reading between 95 and 100 is considered normal. But on different days, Peter says he's at 80, 88, 91, 85, 93, 82, 90, fluctuating from OK, but on the low side, to worryingly low. Rachel had no idea. Peter didn't tell her, and she didn't press him. A few days before Peter dies, their cousin texts,
但彼得在和表亲互发短信讨论血氧水平。95到100之间的读数被认为是正常的。但在不同的日子里，彼得说是在80、88、91、85、93、82、90，在还凑合但偏低，到令人担忧的低点之间波动。瑞秋对此一无所知。彼得没告诉她，她也没追问。在彼得去世前几天，表亲发短信——
"Yo, you good?" My brother doesn't respond. 23 minutes later-- "Ouch, right in the slice"-- meaning ass crack. That's their language for that. And he sends yet another TikTok link.
“喂，你还好吗？”我哥哥没回。23分钟后——“噢，正中靶心”——指屁股沟。那是他们的暗语。他又发来另一个TikTok链接。
Peter's response 10 minutes later is garbled. He's describing his own actions, but it comes out sounding more like a transcript of leery half thoughts.
彼得10分钟后的回复是乱码。他在描述自己的行为，但听起来更像是一堆畏缩的、半截子的想法。
"Try to make things easier. Let's not go back and forth for anything. Go straight to the kitchen. Stay in that chair. Keep thinking of what you need. That way, while you're doing all this, she might get fully winded. Major, most important thing of all is that the chair in the kitchen is a roller chair."
“试着让事情变得简单。我们不要为任何事来回讨论。直接去厨房。待在那张椅子上。保持思考你需要什么。那样，当你做所有这些时，她可能会完全没力气。最重要的事情是，厨房里的那张椅子是带轮子的椅子。”
The roller chair is an office chair Peter is using to get around. In a few days, Rachel is going to find that chair in the kitchen, soaked with urine.
那把转椅是彼得用来移动的办公椅。几天后，瑞秋会在厨房发现那把椅子，上面浸满了尿液。
One last thing Rachael sees in Peter's texts is that she wasn't the only person trying to get him to seek medical help. One family friend was texting information just about every day about clinics he could go to, a nurse who would talk to him.
瑞秋在彼得短信中看到的最后一件事是，她不是唯一一个试图让他寻求医疗帮助的人。有一位家庭朋友几乎每天都在发短信提供他可以去的诊所信息、可以和他通话的护士。
We also don't know what the cousin was saying to Peter in phone calls with him. And he did tell Peter in one text, after Peter told him his blood oxygen reading was 80, that Peter needed to go back to the hospital. Then Peter texted that it went back up to 88, which is still too low and should have sent him to the emergency room, but the moment passed.
我们也不知道表亲在电话里对彼得说了什么。但他确实在一次短信中，在彼得告知血氧读数为80后，告诉彼得他需要回医院。然后彼得发短信说它回升到了88，这仍然太低，本该让他去急诊室，但那个时机错过了。
Peter's neighbor was checking in and leaving food on the porch for him. Four days before he died, Peter texts the neighbor, "I was so exhausted looking at all that food." The neighbor writes back, "Dude, you should go to the hospital. Call an ambulance." Peter-- "Oh, [BLEEP] that."
彼得的邻居一直在关照他，把食物留在门廊。在他去世前四天，彼得给邻居发短信：“看着那堆食物，我累坏了。”邻居回复：“老兄，你应该去医院。打急救电话。”彼得：“噢，[哔——]那吧。”
Peter's last text to his cousin is a sad emoji about the death of the actor William Lucking, who starred in "Sons of Anarchy." The next day, the cousin texted, "How are you doing, Peter?" and got no reply. The day after that, he wrote, "Yo, Jax, please answer me, man."
彼得发给表亲的最后一条短信是一个关于演员威廉·卢金（曾主演《混乱之子》）去世的悲伤表情。第二天，表亲发短信问：“你怎么样了，彼得？”没有收到回复。再过一天，他写道：“嘿，杰克斯，求你回我一下，老兄。”
Rachel told me once about her brother and father and COVID, that it was like they fell overboard during the pandemic and swam straight to the bottom, thinking it was the surface. When she finished reading the texts, she read them again. Her brain kept combing through them for weeks. She couldn't settle on any thought or any feeling.
瑞秋曾经向我提起哥哥和父亲以及新冠，她说这就像他们在疫情期间掉进海里，径直游向了底部，还以为那是表面。当她读完短信后，她又读了一遍。她的大脑在接下来的几周里不断重温这些内容。她无法平静下来去思考或感受什么。
I would go from not being able to speak or to crying or to making fun of my brother. There's the survival mode person who just wants to clown you, like the deep depths of my hoodness. Where I'm from, that particular street I came up on, we would clown you for how you died because you're a fucking clown. Like, you played yourself, homie. You know?
我会从说不出话，变成哭泣，再到取笑我哥哥。生存模式下的人只想调侃你，就像我贫民区性格的深层潜意识。在我出生和长大的那条街上，我们会因为你死的方式取笑你，因为你是个该死的笨蛋。就像，你把自己玩死了，兄弟。你知道吗？
And I would kill some innocent strangers to bring them back, you know? Or would I? I don't know. It's just one of those things where you just haggle. Thinking who you would trade out on the street to get one more shot. And I'm like, you shot your fucking shot, dude.
我会杀掉一些无辜的陌生人来换回他们，你知道吗？或者我会吗？我不知道。这只是那种你不断斤斤计较的事情。思考你在街上会用谁去换回多一次机会。而我对自己说，你已经拼尽全力了，伙计。
Rachel is a poet. That doesn't really cover it, though. Rachel is a tractor beam. I can easily see how a person could hear her read her poetry at some event and then marry her four months later, which happened. I can understand a person wanting to tattoo her words on their arm, which also happened. A lot of Rachel's writing is about her childhood family-- her, her father, her brother.
瑞秋是一位诗人。但这还不足以形容。瑞秋是一道牵引光束。我完全能想象一个人会在某个活动上听她读诗，然后四个月后就娶了她，这确实发生过。我能理解一个人想把她的词纹在手臂上，这也发生过。瑞秋的很多作品都是关于她儿时家庭的——她自己、她的父亲、她的哥哥。
The first poem in her first book is titled, epically, "I forget who I said it to, but I remember how afterwards they looked at me as though I had driven a steak knife through their mother's hand." The poem itself goes, "I love my brother. He had the exact same childhood as I did, but he doesn't get credit for it. He isn't the writer. I'm the star of the violence. I expose. My Peter, when he marries, I will be so sad. No girl in the world deserves him but me."
她第一本书中的第一首诗，宏大地命名为《我忘了告诉谁，但我记得之后他们看我的样子，就像我在他们母亲手上扎了一把牛排刀》。诗本身写道：“我爱我的哥哥。他和我有完全一样的童年，但他没得到赞誉。他不是作家。我是暴力的主角。我揭露。我的彼得，当他结婚时，我会非常难过。世界上没有任何女孩配得上他，除了我。”
I see that poem, which I love, as a little box Rachel is daring her readers to open. Rachel's always seen her place in the world, in part, in relation to Peter, her younger and only brother-- her responsibility still, somehow. She hadn't lived near Peter in almost 20 years, but far away is still somewhere. It's nothing like gone. What do you do when you've lost something important? You retrace your steps.
我把那首诗——我很喜欢那首——看作是瑞秋冒着风险让读者打开的一个小盒子。瑞秋一直把她在世界上的位置，部分地视为与彼得（她唯一的弟弟）的关系——某种程度上仍然是她的责任。她已经有近20年没住在彼得附近了，但远方依然是某个地方。那绝不是消失。当你失去了一些重要的东西，你该怎么办？你重走一遍你的路。
Rachel remembers where she and Peter started, and now she knows where he ended. And she's going back over what happened in between, the things she saw because she was there and the things she's finding out happened later, out of her sight. What did happen in between? What life did COVID land in? That's next time in Part Two of We Were Three.
瑞秋记得她和彼得是从哪里开始的，现在她知道了他是怎么结束的。她正在回溯期间发生的事情，因为她在场而看到的，以及她后来发现的、在她视野之外发生的事情。期间到底发生了什么？新冠降临在怎样的生命中？下一次在《我们是三人组》的第二部分中详述。
Nancy Updike. I'll just say, Episode Two, things get so complicated-- their relationship, the three of them. You can hear that right now, or I guess, after you finish listening to our show. You can get that wherever you get your podcasts. It comes from Serial Productions and The New York Times. Nancy's co-producer for the show is Jenelle Pifer. Her editor is Julie Snyder. Again, the name of the show, We Were Three.
南希·厄普代克。我只想说，第二集，事情变得非常复杂——他们的关系，他们三个人之间。你可以现在就去听，或者我想，听完我们的节目再去。你可以在任何你获取播客的地方收听。节目来自Serial Productions和《纽约时报》。南希的节目共同制作人是詹内尔·派弗。编辑是朱莉·斯奈德。再次声明，节目名称是《我们是三人组》。
[MUSIC - "SWEET OLD WORLD" BY LUCINDA WILLIAMS]
[音乐 - 露辛达·威廉姆斯的《甜蜜旧世界》]
Coming up, family history that a family really doesn't want to talk about that much. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
稍后，一个家庭不太想讨论的家族历史。一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台的节目将继续进行。
It's This American Life, I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, Family Dig, stories of people who take it on themselves to figure out the truth of what exactly went down in their own family, even if it was kind of ugly. We've arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, "The Great Lie-Gration." So now we turn to somebody in this act who tries to excavate his family's past with very few clues to go on.
这里是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目《家族挖掘》，讲述人们为了弄清自己家族到底发生了什么真相，即便真相可能有些丑陋，也决定亲自挖掘的故事。我们进入了节目的第二幕。《第二幕：“伟大的谎言移民”》。现在我们转向这一幕中的某个人，他试图挖掘家族的过去，却几乎没有任何线索。
A few random things about this guy before we get started. First, he is a professional skateboarder, but not into being interviewed or speaking in public. In fact, at the beginning of his interview for our show, which was about something so personal and hard for him to talk about, he asked if it would be OK if he could close his eyes sometimes so that he could focus. And then he kept his eyes closed for the entire conversation. Reporter Gabrielle Emanuel talked to him.
在开始之前，关于这个家伙的一些随记。首先，他是一名职业滑板运动员，但不喜欢接受采访或在公开场合发言。事实上，在为我们节目进行的关于对他来说非常私密且难以启齿的事情的采访开始时，他询问是否可以闭上眼睛，以便专注。然后他在整个谈话过程中一直闭着眼睛。记者加布里埃尔·伊曼纽尔采访了他。
Jahmal Williams didn't know much of his family history growing up. He knew his grandmother had come from Arkansas, settled in Boston. That was about it. They were always kind of vague about the past. But there was one fragment that stuck in his head.
贾马尔·威廉姆斯在成长过程中对家族历史了解不多。他只知道祖母来自阿肯色州，后来定居波士顿。仅此而已。他们对过去总是含糊其辞。但有一段碎片一直萦绕在他脑海中。
I grew up watching PBS. And I remember from time to time, they would have specials on about the Civil Rights movement. And my mom and I would sit down and watch it together. And I remember one time, they were talking about the Freedom Riders. And my mother told me that we were a part of that.
我从小看PBS长大。我记得时不时会有关于民权运动的特别节目。我和妈妈会坐在一起看。我记得有一次，他们在谈论“自由骑手”。妈妈告诉我，我们参与了那场活动。
The Freedom Riders-- activists who boarded Greyhound buses and rode them all over the South in 1961, Black and white people sitting defiantly side by side to challenge segregation.
“自由骑手”——1961年登上灰狗巴士并在整个南方巡回活动的活动家，黑人和白人挑衅地并排坐着，以挑战种族隔离。
And looking at the footage of people being yelled at and people protesting and the water hoses, I was kind of like, wait, wait, wait a second. What do you mean? And she was like, we played a part in the Freedom Rides. I was just like, whoa, what happened, you know? And I had never known anyone in my family to verbally or physically be full-on activist, so that threw me off guard. But it was never talked about too much.
看着那些被叫骂的人、抗议的人和水龙头的镜头，我当时就想，等等，等等，等一下。什么意思？她说，我们参与了“自由骑行”。我当时就想，哇，发生了什么，你知道吗？我从来不知道家里有人在口头上或行动上是彻底的活动家，所以这让我措手不及。但这些事从未多提。
Which Jahmal says was typical for his family. They don't like to talk about the past, even basic things. Like, he always wondered how his family ended up where they did, a neighborhood he sometimes hated. To Jahmal, it was just blank. Then his grandmother died, and he learned more. She was the matriarch of the family, super beloved. The funeral was held at a big church in Boston.
贾马尔说这在他家里很典型。他们不喜欢谈论过去，甚至基本的事情也不谈。比如，他一直想知道他的家族是怎么落到那个地步的，一个他有时很讨厌的社区。对贾马尔来说，那就像一片空白。后来祖母去世了，他了解得更多了。她是家族的族长，非常受爱戴。葬礼在波士顿的一座大教堂举行。
And so my Aunt Satori was speaking about my grandmother. And she was saying my grandmother was a Freedom Rider, and she played a part in history, fighting for the rights of Black Americans. Oh, she was so proud.
我的姑姑萨托里在谈论我的祖母。她说我的祖母是一位“自由骑手”，她在历史中扮演了角色，为美国黑人的权利而战。噢，她当时特别骄傲。
As she talked, she held up a Xerox copy of an old photo of Jahmal's grandmother. Jahmal had never seen the picture before. It looked like it was taken at a bus station. His grandmother's wearing a black dress, white feathery hat, triple string of pearls. It's just her and seven of her kids gathered around her. Jahmal brought that Xerox photo home. It seemed like it might have been clipped from a newspaper. So he pulled up his laptop and started googling her-- Lela Mae Williams.
她说话时，举起了一张贾马尔祖母的旧照片复印件。贾马尔以前从没见过那张照片。照片看起来像是在汽车站拍的。祖母穿着黑色连衣裙、白色羽毛帽，戴着三串珍珠项链。照片里只有她和她的七个孩子围在周围。贾马尔把那张复印件带回了家。看起来像是从报纸上剪下来的。于是他打开笔记本电脑开始用谷歌搜索她——莱拉·梅·威廉姆斯。
I looked and I was surprised to find the photograph online. And I was like, wow, look at this. Here she is. Here's my uncle, and here's my aunts. And just looking at the photo, the photo's amazing. And I was like, wow, look at that. And it said, Reverse Freedom Rides. And I said, wait a second. This is not the Freedom Rides. This is something else.
我查了一下，惊讶地在网上找到了那张照片。我就想，哇，看看这个。她在这里。这是我叔叔，这是我姑姑。看着这张照片，照片太神奇了。我就想，哇，看那个。上面写着“反向自由骑行”。我说，等等。这不是“自由骑行”。这是别的东西。
The Reverse Freedom Rides were a wild chapter in history that had been forgotten. I got fascinated and started researching it a couple of years back. The Reverse Freedom Rides happened in 1962. They were a retaliation against the Freedom Rides by white segregationists in the South. They used the same weapon as the Civil Rights activists, the Greyhound bus, but they used it to send Black people North.
“反向自由骑行”是历史上被遗忘的一个疯狂章节。我被迷住了，两年前开始研究它。“反向自由骑行”发生在1962年。那是南方白人种族隔离主义者对“自由骑行”的报复。他们使用了与民权活动家相同的武器——灰狗巴士，但他们用它把黑人送到北方。
It's kind of like what's happening now with Republican governors loading migrants onto buses and planes and sending them to Democratic states. I thought, it's just like the Reverse Freedom Rides all over again. Some are actually being put up in barracks on the same military base. The goal today is basically the same as it was then-- to stick it to Northerners and make a political point. Here's one of the segregationists back then, Amis Guthridge. He was a lawyer from Arkansas who helped come up with the plan.
有点像现在共和党州长把移民装上巴士和飞机送到民主党州那样。我心想，这简直就是“反向自由骑行”重演。有些人甚至被安置在同一个军事基地的营房里。今天的目标本质上和那时一样——给北方人使绊子，制造政治议题。这是当时的一位种族隔离主义者阿米斯·古特里奇。他是一位来自阿肯色州的律师，协助策划了这个计划。
We're going to find out if people like Mr. Ted Kennedy really do have an interest in the Negro people, really do have a love for the Negro, and a desire to help him. Tell those politicians we are through with this foolishness about civil rights. And if it takes two weeks, two months, two years, five or 10 years, we will continue it until the white people up there--
我们要看看像泰德·肯尼迪先生这样的人是否真的对黑人有兴趣，是否真的爱黑人，并有帮助他的意愿。告诉那些政客，我们受够了关于民权的蠢事。如果需要两周、两个月、两年、五年或十年，我们会继续下去，直到那里的白人——
These segregationists lured people onto the buses with big promises of housing and jobs, said everything would be provided for if they went, and that President Kennedy himself would welcome them up North. They targeted people who might be seen as a burden-- poor families, people just released from prison, single moms with lots of kids, like Jahmal's grandmother. She was raising 11 kids in Arkansas. So they did get on a bus, but it wasn't the Freedom Rides.
这些种族隔离主义者用提供住房和工作的巨大承诺引诱人们登上巴士，称如果他们去了，一切都会提供，肯尼迪总统本人会欢迎他们去北方。他们瞄准那些可能被视为负担的人——贫困家庭、刚从监狱释放的人、带着很多孩子的单身母亲，比如贾马尔的祖母。她在阿肯色州抚养11个孩子。所以他们确实上了巴士，但这并不是“自由骑行”。
Like, these are two different events. And I think I spoke to my mom about it, and she didn't know what it was about. She was like, no, we were Freedom Riders. And I was like, no, this says the Reverse Freedom Rides. And she-- I don't know anything about the Reverse Freedom Rides.
这些是两件完全不同的事情。我想我跟妈妈聊过，她不知道那是怎么回事。她当时说，不，我们是“自由骑手”。我说，不，这上面写的是“反向自由骑行”。她……我对“反向自由骑行”一无所知。
Most people don't. I found out more from archives and old TV footage. There were stories about Jahmal's grandmother in there. And from what we can tell, here's what happened. Guthridge, the segregationist, personally picked up the Williams family in his station wagon. He drove them from their farm to the bus terminal in Little Rock a couple of hours away. He got them ice cream and root beer.
大多数人都不了解。我从档案和旧电视素材中发现了更多。里面有贾马尔祖母的故事。据我们所知，事情是这样的：种族隔离主义者古特里奇亲自开车把威廉姆斯一家接走。他开车把他们从农场送到了几小时路程外的小石城巴士站。他给他们买了冰淇淋和沙士汽水。
There was a quick press conference, and then they all got on the bus-- hardly any luggage because they'd been told everything would be provided up North. There's actually footage of the moment they got on the bus. There's no sound, so I'll describe it for you.
进行了一场简短的新闻发布会，然后他们都上了巴士——几乎没什么行李，因为他们被告知到了北方一切都会得到提供。事实上还有他们上巴士那一刻的视频。没有声音，所以我来为你描述。
The kids have big smiles. They look excited to be filmed. They're chewing gum, waving out the window. As she boards, Lela Mae looks back over her shoulder. She looks beautiful, elegant in a strappy sequined dress and bright white cap. The video is just 29 seconds long, but Lela Mae looks ready.
孩子们笑得很灿烂。他们看起来对被拍摄感到兴奋。他们嚼着口香糖，向窗外挥手。莱拉·梅在上车时回头看了一眼。她看起来很美，穿着饰有亮片的吊带裙，戴着雪白的帽子，优雅动人。视频只有29秒，但莱拉·梅看起来准备好了。
After about three days on the bus, Lela Mae asked the bus driver to pull over. She wanted to change into her best clothes because she was about to meet President Kennedy. That's when she put on those pearls that Jahmal saw on the photo. But when she was dropped off near the Kennedy compound in Hyannis, Massachusetts, Kennedy wasn't there. Neither were the jobs or the housing. It had all been lies. What was there were some members of the NAACP, some people from a church group, and photographers with their flashes going off.
在巴士上过了大约三天后，莱拉·梅要求司机停车。她想换上她最好的衣服，因为她即将见到肯尼迪总统。那时她戴上了贾马尔在照片上看到的那串珍珠。但当她被送到马萨诸塞州海恩尼斯肯尼迪庄园附近时，肯尼迪并不在那里。工作和住房也没有。那一切都是谎言。在那里的是一些全国有色人种协进会(NAACP)的成员、一些教会团体的人，以及闪光灯闪烁个不停的摄影师。
So, tell me, what was going through your head as you started finding this all out?
那么，告诉我，当你开始发现这一切时，你脑子里在想什么？
I mean, in a way, I was not necessarily hurt by it, but I guess somewhat embarrassed that there was this trickery done, and my family was taken advantage of. Because I felt like they were being used, especially the way my mother spoke about it and the way my aunt-- they were proud of being Freedom Riders. And I was like, no. Grandma was actually used as a pawn. She was taken advantage of and used as a political pawn.
从某种程度上讲，我并不是感到受伤，但我猜多少有点尴尬，因为竟然发生了这种诡计，我的家人被利用了。因为我觉得他们被当成了筹码，尤其是妈妈和姑姑提起它时的那种骄傲语气——她们以为自己是自由骑手。而我心想，不。祖母实际上被当作了棋子。她被占了便宜，并被当作政治棋子利用了。
But it did answer a question he'd always had.
但这确实回答了他一直以来的一个问题。
I always wondered, how did we wind up in the projects? Like, where did we come from, you know?
我一直想知道，我们是怎么住进政府公屋的？我们是从哪里来的，你知道吗？
Jahmal grew up in a big public housing development in Boston. His entire family lived there. And now he knew why. His family was dumped up North far from everyone they knew. No jobs and had to figure things out. Jahmal's eyes were still closed at this point in the interview.
贾马尔在波士顿的一个大型公屋项目里长大。他的全家都住在那。现在他知道原因了。他的家人被丢到了北方，远离所有他们认识的人。没有工作，不得不自己设法解决。采访到这时，贾马尔依然闭着眼睛。
I didn't like the life we were living. I didn't like the neighborhood I lived in. I didn't like the jobs my mother had to do. So there was a lot of, why are things the way they are?
我不喜欢我们当时过的生活。我不喜欢我居住的社区。我不喜欢妈妈不得不做的工作。所以当时有很多疑问：为什么事情会变成这样？
Nobody knows why his grandmother ended up on that bus, whether she was forced or tricked or chose it, thinking a move North would be best. It's been years since Jahmal first learned about the Reverse Freedom Rides. He told me he sees it differently now. His grandmother had a one-way ticket and no resources and somehow made it work. He's proud of that.
没人知道他的祖母为何最终上了那辆巴士，是被迫的、被骗的，还是她做出的选择，以为搬到北方会更好。距离贾马尔第一次了解“反向自由骑行”已经过去很多年了。他告诉我他现在看法不同了。他的祖母拿着一张单程票，没有任何资源，却以某种方式让一家人活了下来。他为此感到自豪。
My grandmother was just trying to make a better way for our family. And that's all she's ever done. And that's all my mother's ever done, so who wouldn't think that, wow, this is our way out of Jim Crow South, you know? So I don't know how they were able to judge, are these guys up to no good? I don't know how anyone at the time would have dealt with that.
我的祖母只是想为我们的家庭寻找一条更好的出路。那是她做过的一切。那也是我妈妈做过的一切，所以谁会不觉得，哇，这是我们走出吉姆·克劳法南方的方式，你知道吗？所以我不知道他们当时如何判断，这些家伙是不是没安好心？我不知道当时任何人该如何应对那种情况。
Like other things from their past, Jahmal's family doesn't talk much about this history. Sometimes, when things are traumatic, you make the choice not to go there. It's just not helpful. And sometimes, it's not even a choice. Jahmal's brought up the Reverse Freedom Rides a couple of times with his mom.
就像他们过去的其它事情一样，贾马尔的家人不常谈论这段历史。有时，当事情具有创伤性，你会选择不去触碰。这确实没用。有时，这甚至不是选择。贾马尔曾几次和妈妈提起“反向自由骑行”。
I knew she didn't want to talk about it. She may even have difficulty understanding it now, even still, just because of the emotional experience. If it got too dark, she wouldn't go there. But she would talk about some of the fond memories about growing up in the South. But some stuff, she wouldn't go there. That's just how she was. And she didn't want to talk about this because I don't think it was a pleasant experience for her.
我知道她不想谈论。她现在可能也很难理解这一切，仅仅因为那种情感经历。如果事情变得太沉重，她就不会去碰它。但她会谈论在南方成长的一些美好记忆。但有些东西，她绝口不提。她就是那样的人。她不想谈论这个，因为我不认为这对她来说是什么愉快的经历。
I've known his mom, Betty, for a few years. She was a teenager when she took the bus North. She wants to talk about it. She's really trying. But it's not that simple.
我认识他妈妈贝蒂几年了。她坐那趟巴士去北方时还是个青少年。她想谈论这件事。她真的在努力。但这并不简单。
I guess when you get to be an adult, you just kind of block out things or things you just don't want to remember. I don't know what it is, but I don't remember a lot about the bus. I don't even remember none of that stuff. I don't remember.
我猜当你成年后，你只是会封存一些事情，或者你就是不想去记起那些。我不知道是什么原因，但我对那辆巴士没什么记忆。我甚至什么都不记得了。我记不得了。
Sometimes, the past is something only the next generation can really look at. A while back, Jahmal was at home, sketching on a canvas-- he's also an artist-- thinking about the Reverse Freedom Rides, his grandmother, and his mom. And then his son, who was 10, walked in and noticed Jahmal was crying. Jahmal let him know it was OK. These were good tears. He says one day, when he's older, he'll tell them about it. They weren't activists on buses headed South. They were survivors on buses headed North.
有时，过去只有下一代才能真正审视。不久前，贾马尔在家里的画布上写生——他也是个艺术家——想着“反向自由骑行”、他的祖母和他妈妈。这时，他10岁的儿子走进来，注意到贾马尔在哭。贾马尔让他知道没事。那是幸福的泪水。他说有一天，当他再大一点，他会告诉他们这件事。他们不是坐在前往南方的巴士上的活动家。他们是坐在前往北方的巴士上的幸存者。
Gabrielle Emanuel, she's a reporter at WBUR in Boston. On our website this week, we have the news footage that she mentions in her story of Lela Mae Williams and her kids getting on that bus back in the 1960s in Arkansas. Plus, we have links to other stories that Gabrielle has done about the Reverse Freedom Rides, where she goes into more depth about this history and the Williams family. This story was produced by Lilly Sullivan.
加布里埃尔·伊曼纽尔，她是波士顿WBUR的记者。本周在我们的网站上，有她在报道中提到的莱拉·梅·威廉姆斯和孩子们在60年代阿肯色州登上那辆巴士的新闻镜头。此外，还有加布里埃尔制作的关于“反向自由骑行”的其他故事链接，她在那里更深入地探讨了这段历史和威廉姆斯一家。这个故事由莉莉·沙利文制作。
[MUSIC - "HERCULES," BY AARON NEVILLE]
[音乐 - 亚伦·内维尔的《赫拉克勒斯》]
Well, our program was produced today by Miki Meek. The people who put together today's show include Elna Baker, Zoe Chace, Sean Cole, Michael Comite, who's also the music supervisor for We Were Three, Aviva DeKornfeld, Valerie Kipnis, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Charlotte Sleeper, Frances Swanson, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, and Julie Whitaker. Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry.
我们的节目今天由米基·米克制作。参与制作今天节目的包括埃尔娜·贝克、佐伊·蔡斯、肖恩·科尔、迈克尔·科米特（他也是《我们是三人组》的音乐主管）、阿维娃·德科恩菲尔德、瓦莱丽·基普尼斯、斯托·尼尔森、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、夏洛特·斯里珀、弗朗西丝·斯旺森、克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼和朱莉·惠特克。我们的执行主编是萨拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼。高级编辑是戴维·凯斯滕鲍姆。执行编辑是伊曼纽尔·贝里。
Special thanks today to Anthony Almojera, Rana Awdish, Taison Bell, Trevor Bedford, Rachel Bender Ignacio, Jeremy Faust, Kristen Panthagani, Jason Salemi, Mark Shapiro, Ernie Dumas, Mary-Beth Brague, Gene Guill, Kristen Harper, and Clive Webb.
特别感谢今天的安东尼·阿尔莫赫拉、拉娜·阿迪什、泰森·贝尔、特雷弗·贝德福德、瑞秋·本德·伊格纳西奥、杰里米·浮士德、克里斯汀·潘塔加尼、杰森·萨莱米、马克·夏皮罗、厄尼·杜马斯、玛丽-贝斯·布拉格、吉恩·吉尔、克里斯汀·哈珀和克莱夫·韦伯。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org, where you can stream our archive of over 750 episodes for absolutely free. Also, there's videos. There's a list of favorite shows to try out, tons of other stuff. Again, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. He explains why he never loads anything into the dishwasher this way.
我们的网站 thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以免费流媒体收听我们超过750期的节目存档。此外，还有视频。有一个最爱节目推荐列表，以及大量其他内容。再次提醒，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由PRX（公共广播交换中心）提供给公共广播电台。一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人托瑞·马拉蒂亚先生。他解释了为什么他从不在洗碗机里装东西，他是这样说的。
I don't really know how to operate it, I'll be honest. I'm not interested in it.
坦白说，我不知道怎么操作。我不感兴趣。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周回到《美国生活》带来更多故事。
[MUSIC - "HERCULES," BY AARON NEVILLE]
[音乐 - 亚伦·内维尔的《赫拉克勒斯》]